depuis longtemps on n'a pas vu de telle
heure de tel et de talent
d'affrontements entre l'armée libanaise
et entre les manifestants et surtout à
tripoli et donc aujourd'hui le
gouvernement qui a tout d'abord demandé
au ministre au ministre des finances de
demander au gouverneur de la bdl de la
banque du liban de présenter un relevé
qui montre qu'elles sont les comptes qui
ont transféré des capitaux à l'étranger
et surtout après la révolution de 17
octobre
il y aura demain une réunion du conseil
des ministres exceptionnel afin de finir
le projet de le projet de de lutte
contre la corruption qui a été préparé à
par le gouvernement et donc ça sera une
sorte de papier économique qui on va
mettre par big four à part peut-être
mettre fin mais qui va commencer à
travailler contre la corruption afin de
mettre des de prendre des mesures qui
sont un véritable afin de pouvoir
apaiser la colère qui est dans le dans
lequel la colère premier les citoyens
libanais pour peindre il ya une crise
politique une crise sur sur ce qu'il ya
sur le sur une prise de pouvoir et je
pense pas qu'il ya avantage pour
n'importe quel parti de revenir à la
guerre civile qui repousse aussi et que
aujourd'hui est là le message qui est
venue des nations unies et surtout du
représentant des nations unies est
éclair dans le sens qu' il faut pas
utiliser les tripolitains est compact et
les amis libanais afin de m'envoyer des
messages dans des directions
ici on doit on doit affronter à eau
aux affrontements aussi qui se déroulait
et qui se passait à tripoli depuis
plusieurs années et qui ont duré pour
quatre ou cinq ans il ya certainement
une crainte de revenir à 7 à cette image
de à tripoli mais je pense pas que
quiconque al'avantage aux 2,1 refaire ou
bien de reprendre la guerre civile au
liban